[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: All
right, OK, so let's start.
We're talking about music
today, which is fun and awesome.
But first, let me give you
a brief whirlwind reminder
of what we did last time.
We talked about hearing
in general and speech
in particular.
And we started, as usual,
with computational theory,
thinking about what is
the problem of audition
and what is sound.
It's the first step of that.
And sound is pressure waves
traveling through the air.
And the cool thing
about hearing is
that we extract
lots of information
from this very, very
simple signal of pressure
waves arriving at the ear.
We use it to recognize
sounds, to localize sounds,
to figure out what
things are made of,
and to understand events around
us, and all kinds of things.
And these problems are a
major computational challenge.
And in particular,
they are ill-posed.
That means that the available
information doesn't give you
a unique solution
if you consider
the computational
problem narrowly.
And that's true for
separating sound sources.
So if you have two
sound sources at once,
say, two people speaking or
a person speaking and a lot
of background noise, that's
known as the cocktail party
problem.
Those sounds add on
top of each other.
And there's no way to pull
them apart without bringing
in other information,
knowledge about the world
or knowledge about the
nature of voices or speaking
or who's speaking.
Or you need something else,
or else it's ill-posed.
That is not solvable just
from the basic input.
Another case of an ill-posed
problem in audition
is the case of reverb.
So the sound that I'm making
right now that's coming out
my mouth is bouncing
off the walls
and is arriving at your ears
over each little piece of sound
that I make is arriving
at different latencies
after I say it as it travels
different paths bouncing
around the room.
There's not too
much reverb in here,
so it's not that noticeable.
But if we did this
in a cathedral,
you'd hear all these echoes.
OK, and so that makes
another ill-posed problem,
because all of those
different sounds
are added on top of themselves
diminished in volume over time.
And you get the sum
of all of those,
and you have to pull
it apart and figure out
what that sound is.
So both problems
are solved by using
knowledge of the real world.
In the case of reverb, it's
actual implicit knowledge
that you all have
that you didn't
know you have about
the physics of reverb.
Because if we play you
sounds with the wrong physics
of reverb, you won't be
able to deal with reverb.
And that says it's implicit
knowledge in your head, which
is pretty cool, that
you use to constrain
the ill-posed problem.
We talked about speech.
Phonemes are sounds
that distinguish
two different words in a
language, like make and bake.
Those are two
different sounds that
make the difference
between two words.
Each possible speech
sound is not a phoneme
in every language of the world.
Languages have some subset of
the space of possible phonemes
that distinguish words
in their language.
Phonemes include vowels that
have these stacked harmonics
in the spectrogram,
and consonants
which are the quick transitions
in the vertical stripes
in the spectrogram, leading into
the harmonic stacks of vowels.
We talked about the problem
of talker variability,
that a given phoneme or
word sounds very different,
looks very different
in the spectrogram
if spoken by two
different people.
And conversely, the same person
speaking two different words
looks very different
in the spectrogram.
And so that means
that the identity
of the speaker and the
identity of the word being said
are all mushed up together.
And that means that if
you want to recognize
the voice independent
of what's being said,
or recognize the word
independent of who's saying it,
you have a big computational
challenge, a classic invariance
problem.
Yeah, Ben.
AUDIENCE: I don't
mean to hold us up.
I just wanted to make sure
that I'm understanding.
So the difference between
consonants and vowels,
are vowels just harmonic,
like connective elements
between consonants?
And are consonants
the percussive?
Or are they actual--
like, I just didn't
understand that.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, so
in the spectrogram, those--
I didn't put that
on the slide here--
but those horizontal red
stripes in the slides
that I showed you last time,
those in the spectrogram, those
are bands of energy at
different frequencies
that are sustained
over a chunk of time.
And those are typical of
vowels, or singing or musical.
And those harmonic
sounds that have pitch.
And so vowels have
those sustained chunks
that look like this
in the spectrogram.
And then there are these
weird vertical stripes
and transitions in
and out of the vowels
that are the consonants.
AUDIENCE: Vowels
are when you don't
have [INAUDIBLE] spectrographs
because air is just
flowing through and you're
filtering it somehow,
like positioning your vocal
tract in a certain way.
And consonants are when
you close off that air
or restrict it in some way.
So like S's and F's, you're
not closing all the way off,
but you're really
constricting the vocal tract.
And in a lot of
other consonants,
you're actually
fully closing it.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
and then we talked a bit
about the brain basis.
And I pointed out that
the neural anatomy
of sound processing-- the
subcortical neuroanatomy
is much more complicated than
the subcortical neuroanatomy
of vision.
In vision, you have
one stop in the LGN,
and then you go up to the cortex
coming up from the retina.
In audition, you have many
stops between the cochlea, where
you pick up sounds in the
inner ear, and auditory cortex.
Some of those stops
are shown up here.
And we didn't discuss them.
So then we talked about
primary auditory cortex.
That's on the top of
the temporal lobes,
like right in there medially.
You went in.
And it has this
tonotopic property,
and that is a map of frequency
space with this systematic
high-low-high mapping of
frequency space that you can
see here--
high, low, high, like that.
This is the top of the
temporal lobe right there.
And I pointed out that in
animals and in one recent MRI
study, the response properties
of primary auditory cortex
are well modeled by these fairly
simple linear filters, known
as spectrotemporal receptive
fields or STRFs, shown here.
So they're simple
acoustic properties
of a given band of
frequencies rising or falling
at different rates.
So today, we're going
to talk about music.
And this is also an important
moment in the course.
Because up to now, we've been
talking about functions that
are mostly shared with animals.
Speech is kind of on the cusp.
I was going to make this
point before speech.
And that's actually muddy,
because lots of animals
are really good at
speech perception.
Chinchillas can
distinguish ba from pa.
Go figure, anyway.
So they can perceive
speech, but obviously they
don't use it in the same way.
But music is most
definitely uniquely human.
And so most of the things we'll
be talking about from here
on out are things about the
human brain, in particular.
And I think these are
the coolest things
in human cognitive neuroscience,
because they tell us something
about who we are
as human beings.
But they are also the
hardest ones to study.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER:
No animal models.
And I'm always lamenting
how-- about the shortcomings
of each of the methods in
human cognitive neuroscience.
And we have lots of them, and
they complement each other,
but there's a whole
host of things
that none of those
methods are good for.
And so now we're
really out on thin ice
trying to understand
these things with a weaker
set of methods where we can't
go back and validate them
with animal models.
And that's just life.
That's what we do.
So now let's back
up for a second
and consider, why am I
allocating a whole lecture
for such a fluffy,
frivolous topic as music.
And I would say, that's
because it's not fluffy.
It's actually fundamental.
And it's fundamental
in the sense
that music is both
uniquely human--
no other animal has anything
remotely like human music--
and it's also universally human.
That is, every human
culture that's been studied
has some kind of music.
So music is really
an essential part
of what it means to
be a human being.
It's really at the
core of humanity.
And that alone makes
it interesting.
But further-- question?
AUDIENCE: So, like, birdsong--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Birdsong doesn't count.
No, birdsong doesn't count
in all kinds of ways.
One, it doesn't have
anywhere near the flexibility
and variability.
There are like narrow domains
in which each male zebra
finch makes a slightly
different version of the call,
but within an
extremely narrow range.
There's actually a
brain imaging study
that looks in brain imaging
in songbirds and asks,
do they have reward brain
region responses to music.
And the answer is,
yes, in some cases.
Like, do they enjoy it,
right, is that part of--
and the answer is
yes, but only when
the significance of the
birdsong is something that's
relevant to them, like, there's
a potential mate right here,
then they like it.
But they don't like
it just for the sound.
And that makes it very
different from humans.
And there are other
differences as well.
So it's further
really important to us
humans in a whole bunch of ways.
One, we have been doing
it for a very long time.
And so, for example, the
archaeological record shows
these 40,000-year-old bone
flutes that you can see from
the structure of flute make
particular sets of possible
pitches.
And further, most people
who've thought about this
have argued that singing
probably goes back much farther
than the bone flutes.
After all, you don't have
to make anything to do it.
You can just sing.
Some have even
speculated that singing
evolved before language.
It's just speculation,
but that's possible.
In any case, it goes
way back evolutionarily.
It also arises early
in development.
So very young infants are
extremely interested in music.
They're sensitive to beat and
melody, independent of pitch.
We'll talk more about
that a little bit.
And finally, if
you're not impressed
with any of those
arguments, people
spend a lot of money on music.
And if that's your
index of importance,
it's really important.
Last year, $43 billion in sales.
So I'd say it's not
a frivolous topic.
It's a fundamental topic.
It's near the core of what
it means to be a human being.
And all of this raises a
really obvious question.
Why do we create and like
music in the first place?
What is it for?
And this is a puzzle that people
have thought about for at least
centuries, probably millennia.
And this includes all
kinds of major thinkers,
like Darwin, who said,
"As neither the enjoyment
nor the capacity of
producing musical notes
are faculties of
the least direct use
to man in reference to his
ordinary habits of life,
they must be ranked amongst
the most mysterious with which
he is endowed."
So Darwin is implicitly
assuming here
that music is an
evolved capacity.
It's not something that we just
learn and that cultures invent,
if they feel like it
or don't feel like it.
But it's actually evolved and
shaped by natural selection.
And that means there
must be some function
that natural selection
was acting on that
was relevant to survival.
So people have speculated about
what that function might be.
Those who think that music
is an evolved function,
including Darwin, he speculated
that it's for sexual selection.
And his writing is so beautiful,
I won't paraphrase it.
He says, "It appears probable
that the progenitors of man,
either the males or
females or both sexes,
before acquiring the power of
expressing their mutual love
in articulate
language, endeavored
to charm each other with
musical notes and rhythm."
So that's Darwin's speculation.
It's just a speculation,
but a lovely one.
Also, note that he threw away
this radical idea in here:
"before acquiring the power
to express their mutual love
in articulate language."
So he's speculating that
music came before language.
Again, all speculation, but
interesting speculation.
More recently, up
the street, there's
a bunch of people who've been
thinking about this a lot.
And Sam Mehr at Harvard
has been arguing
that the function
of music and song,
in particular, which
he thinks is really
the fundamental basic kind
of native form of music,
has an evolutionary
role in managing
parent-offspring conflict.
And that's something that
many evolutionary theorists
have written about.
The genetic interests of
a parent and an offspring
are highly overlapping, but
not completely overlapping.
The parent has other
offspring to take care
of besides this one right here.
That one right there wants
100% of the parent's effort.
Therein lies the conflict.
And so Mehr has proposed
that infant directed
song arose in this
kind of arms race
between the somewhat competing
interests of the parent
and the offspring.
And it manages this
need the infant has
to know the parent is
there with the fact
that the parent has other
needs, so i guess idea
they can sing while attending to
other offspring, and on and on.
So there's other kinds of
speculations like this.
But importantly, this is
not the only kind of view.
It's not necessarily
the case that music
is an evolved capacity.
So others have
argued that it's not.
So Steve Pinker,
also up the street,
has argued that
music is "auditory
cheesecake, an exquisite
confection crafted
to tickle the sensitive
spots of at least six
of our mental faculties.
If it vanished from our species,
the rest of our lifestyle
would be virtually unchanged."
I think that might say a
little more about Steve Pinker
than it does about music.
Nonetheless, it's
a possible view.
What he's saying is
that music is not
an evolutionary
adaptation at all,
but an alternate use
of neural machinery
that evolved for
some other function.
And then once you have
this neural machinery, what
the hell, you can
invent cultural forms
and use it to do other
things like music.
And the most obvious
kind of neural machinery
that you might co-opt
for that function
would be neural machinery for
speech or neural machinery
for language, which, as I
argued briefly last time,
are not the same thing.
One is the auditory
perception of speech sounds
and the other is
the understanding
of linguistic meaning.
So the nice thing
about this is, finally
after all this entertaining
but speculative stuff,
we have an empirical question.
This is something we
can ask empirically.
Does music actually
use the same machinery
as speech or language,
or does it not?
Some of the rest of
these speculations
are very hard to test.
So stay tuned.
We'll get back to that shortly.
But first, let's step
back and think, OK,
if music is an evolved
capacity, it should
be innate in some sense,
at least genetically
specified, right, because
that's what evolution does
is that natural selection acts
on the genome to produce things
that are genetically specified.
And it should be present
in all human societies,
since the branching
out of human societies
is very recent in
human evolution.
So is it?
Well, is music an innate?
So, suppose we found specialized
machinery in the brain
and adults for music.
And we showed
really definitively,
it's really, really, really
specialized for music.
Would that prove innateness?
No, why not?
AUDIENCE: Might
have [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Bingo,
thank you, very good.
Yup, exactly.
So this is something that many,
many people are confused about,
including colleagues
of mine, most
of the popular scientific press.
Just because there's a
specialized bit of brain
that does x doesn't
mean x is innate.
It could be learned.
And the clearest example of that
is the visual word form area.
Everybody get that?
OK, so we've got to
try something else.
What if we find sensitivity
to music, in some very music
particular way, in newborns?
Now that will get closer,
but here's the problem.
Fetuses can hear pretty
well in the womb.
And if the mom is singing
or even if there's
music in the ambient
room, some of that sound
gets into the womb.
So that means that even if you
show sensitivity to music, even
in some very particular
way, in a newborn,
it's not a really tight argument
that it wasn't, in part,
learned.
So this is a real challenge.
It may just be
impossible to answer.
I'm not sure.
I don't know how--
I don't know what method
could actually answer this.
But at the very least,
it's really difficult
and nobody's nailed it.
So we can backtrack and
ask the related, not quite
as definitive question: "But
OK, how early developing is it?"
So often, developmental
psychologists take this hedge.
It's like, we can't
exactly establish
definitive innateness.
But if things are
really there very early
and develop very fast,
that's a suggestion
that at least the system is
designed to pick it up quickly.
So even if there's a
role for experience,
there's some things that are
picked up really fast and some
things that aren't.
And so how quickly
is it picked up?
So it turns out there's
a bunch of studies
that have looked at this.
And young infants are in
fact highly attuned to music.
They're sensitive to
pitch and to rhythm.
And in one charming
study, they took two
to three-day-old infants
who were sleeping,
put EEG electrodes on
them, and played them.
They wanted to test
beat induction, which is
when you hear a rhythmic beat.
You get trained to the beat.
And you know when
the next beat is.
And that's true even if it's
not just a single pulse.
So they played these
infants sounds like this.
Oh, but the audio is not on.
Now it's going to
blast everyone.
All right, hang on.
AUDIENCE: It's playing.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Oh, it is playing?
Turn up more?
OK.
Didn't want to deafen people.
OK, here.
AUDIENCE: It's going
a little [INAUDIBLE]..
Just turn it up so
you can hear it.
AUDIENCE: Go to
HDMI, [INAUDIBLE]
plugged in [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: It's not, but
that's supposed to work, right?
It has worked before
AUDIENCE: In there.
AUDIENCE: Let's just check your
system settings really quickly.
So I can hear you
from my system.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, it's weird.
AUDIENCE: Wait, if I can hear
you from my system, you're--
NANCY KANWISHER: Then,
it is going out, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, somebody
unplugged both.
OK, let's try [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Aah.
AUDIENCE: OK, try
it one more time.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Did you hear that glitch?
Let me do it again.
Take it back here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Everybody here the
hiccup in the beat?
So that's what
these guys tested.
They played rhythms like that
to two to three-day-old infants.
And--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh, now it's working.
OK, great.
OK, anyway, so here's what
they find with their ERPs.
This is the onset of that
little hiccup, the time when
that beat was supposed to
happen and didn't, the missing
beat right there.
And this is an ERP
response happening
about 200 milliseconds later for
that missing but expected beat.
And let's see,
this is a standard
where the beat keeps going.
Now you might say, well, of
course they're different.
One has a beat there
and one doesn't.
They're acoustically different.
So they have a control
condition which
has a beat, but a different
preceding context.
So where that beat is not--
I'm sorry, where it
has a missing beat,
but that's expected by
the previous context.
So that's just evidence
that even young infants
have some sense of beat.
So moving a little later,
by five to six months,
infants can recognize
a familiar melody,
even if it's shifted in
pitch from the version
that they learned.
And that's really
cool, because that
means they use relative
pitch, not absolute pitch.
And that's something
that adults do in music.
We're very good at that.
But no animal can do that.
You can train animals to do
various things like recognize
a particular pair
of sounds or even
a few sounds, a few pitches.
But if you transpose it,
they don't recognize that.
Yeah, Ben.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
possible that we're
just sensitive to
rhythm and pitch
rather than being
sensitive to music itself?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes,
hang on to that thought.
It takes more work to show
that it's music per se
rather than just
rhythm and pitch.
We'd have to say what
we meant by rhythm.
If we load enough into
the idea of rhythm, then
it's like most of
music right there.
But we might say just even beat.
How about that, right?
And actually, already
this study already
is not just an even
beat, because it
has more context than that.
That is, for example, the
beats in this ERP infant study
were not emphasized louder.
The infants have to be able
to pick out what the beat is
from that complex sound.
It's not automatically
there in the acoustic signal
as the louder onset sound.
Five-month-old
infants, if you play
them a melody for one
or two weeks, so they
get really familiar
with it and learn it,
and then you don't play it again
and you come back eight months
later, they remember it.
So music is really
salient to infants.
On the other hand, newborn
infants' appreciation of music
is not--
what is that not doing there?
Oh, yeah, that's right.
So they don't prefer consonance
over dissonance, right.
And they're insensitive to key.
And they detect timing
changes in rhythms,
whether they are
timing changes that
are typical in the
kind of music they've
heard or typical in a more
foreign kind of music.
And so a really nice
study that shows this
is that in Western music,
it's really common to have--
most Western music
has isochronous beat.
So you can see that over here.
Here's an isochronous beat.
Those are even,
temporal intervals.
And there's a whole note
here and then half notes.
And they're all multiples
of each other, just wholes
and halves, with the beat
happening every four notes.
Non-isochronous beat has
this funny business where
there's a whole note and a half
note, making up just three--
what do you call those things--
they're not beats.
What are they called?
AUDIENCE: Three-beat notes.
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry,
three notes, I guess.
But it's not even notes,
because it's whatever.
I don't know what
the terminology is.
But anyway, this sound
here followed by 4.
This is non-isochronous rhythm.
Those are really
common in Balkan music
where they do all kinds
of crazy things, like 8/22
or something like that.
I mean, like really, really
crazy musical meters.
They're awesome, I love them.
But they are very other.
Like, if you grew up
in Western society
when you first hear
Balkan rhythms,
it's very hard to copy them.
But six-month-old
infants get rhythms
equally well if they're
isochronous or non-isochronous.
By 12 months, they can
only get automatically,
like immediately,
perceive and appreciate
rhythms that are familiar
from their cultural exposure.
That is isochronous if
they're from a Western society
or non-isochronous if they're
from a Balkan country.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: just what is
getting a meter again?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Well, so there's
a whole bunch of studies.
I'm just summarizing here.
That is, they're sensitive
to violations by all kinds
of measures of little whatever
behavioral thing you can get
out of a five-month-old, whether
it's how much they're kicking
their legs or how much--
often, it's how
hard they're sucking
on a pacifier is
another measure.
So you just see, can
they detect changes
in a stimulus or violations
by any of those measures.
Or you could do
it with the ERPs.
So brief exposure to a
previously unfamiliar rhythm
is enough for a
12-month-old to appreciate
the relevant distinctions
in that rhythm,
but not for adults.
So if you haven't heard
non-isochronous Balkan rhythms
until now and you try dancing
to them, good luck to you.
You can probably
get it eventually,
but it will take
you a long time.
So does this sound familiar?
Perceptual narrowing, right?
So we keep encountering this.
We encountered this
with face recognition,
with same versus other races,
same versus other species.
You see it in face recognition.
We encountered it with
phoneme perception.
The phonemes-- remember,
newborn infants can distinguish
all the phonemes of
the world's languages,
even those exotic clicks
that I played last time
from Southern African languages.
And you guys can't distinguish
all those clicks now.
So that's perceptual narrowing.
It makes sense, of course,
because the reason we
have perceptual narrowing is
you want to have invariants.
You want to appreciate
the sameness of things
across transformations.
And if your speech culture
or your music culture
is telling you these two things,
this variation, doesn't count,
you want to throw
away that difference
and treat them as the same.
And then once you do that, you
can't make that discrimination
anymore.
So on this question
we started with,
is music an evolved capacity.
If so, it should be innate.
And we haven't really
answered that question, maybe.
But as I said, it's really
hard, and maybe ultimately
unanswerable.
But certainly it's
early developing.
What about this other question?
Is it present in
all human societies?
Well, I said before
briefly that it is.
Oh yeah, sorry, we have
to back up and say, OK,
to answer this question, we
have to say what is music.
To answer whether it's
present in all societies.
And this has been a real
problem, because music
is notoriously hard to define.
And many people
have made a point
of stretching the definition
of music, including
the ridiculous and
hilarious John Cage.
So this is his
1960 TV appearance.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Over here, Mr. Cage has
a tape recording machine,
which will provide much of
the-- will you touch the machine
so we can know where it
is-- which will provide much
of the background.
Also, he works with a stopwatch.
The reason he does this
is because these sounds
are in no sense accidental
in their sequence.
They each must
fall mathematically
at a precise point.
So he wants to
watch as he works.
He takes it seriously.
I think it's interesting.
If you are amused,
you may laugh.
If you like it, you
may buy the recording.
John Cage and "Water Walk."
[EXPERIMENTAL MUSICAL SOUNDS]
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: Anyway, it
goes on and on like that.
I guess it was a little
edgier in 1959 than it is now.
But he's making a point.
He's making a point is,
what the hell is music.
And he's saying, I can
call this music if I want.
And everybody's enjoying it.
Anyway.
So you can watch the
YouTube video, if you want.
It's quite entertaining.
Despite this kind
of nihilistic view
that anything could
count is music,
there are some
things we can say.
First thing I'd say is, if
you want to study music,
one of your first
things you run into
is, oh, what's going to count.
You run into this problem here.
But actually, I
think that doesn't
need to be so paralyzing
as it feels at first.
You can just take the most
canonical forms where all
of your subjects will agree that
this is music and this isn't.
And then someday you can
study the edge cases later,
but you don't need to agonize
about them in order to get off
the ground and study it.
Further, we can ask what
is music cross-culturally.
Oh, right, I keep
forgetting my next point.
And let me make another point
is that music is not just
about a set of
acoustic properties.
You may think of music as
just an auditory thing,
a solitary experience, because a
lot of the time it's like that.
But remember that that's a
very recent cultural invention.
And throughout most
of human evolution,
music has been a fundamentally
social phenomenon, more
like this, experienced
in groups of people
as a kind of deeply social,
communicative, interactive kind
of enterprise.
Or even if not in a
large group, music
is very social in
this sense here.
There's a whole bunch of cool
studies about the role of song
in infants and how infants
use song to glean information
about their social environment.
And the point is just
music is extremely social.
It's not just defined by
its acoustic properties.
But in addition, we
can ask, OK, let's
look across the cultures
of the world and ask,
are there universals of music?
Is there anything in common
across all the different kinds
of music that people experience
in different cultures?
For example, are there always
discrete pitches or always
isochronous beats.
I already showed you
there aren't always
isochronous beats.
And this is nice because
it's an empirical question.
There's a really cool
paper from a few years ago
where they took
recordings of music
from all over the world,
all those colored dots,
and they asked, what
are the properties that
are present in most
of those musics
and how prevalent are they.
And what they found is there's
no single property of music
that's present in all
of those cultures,
but there's many that
are present in most,
and there are a lot
of regularities.
So this is a huge
table from their paper
where they list many
different possible universals.
And what you see is the relevant
column is this one here.
And the white is the percent
of those 304 cultures
that they looked at that have
that property in their music.
So these top ones
are very prevalent,
just not quite universal,
because there's
a couple of cases
that don't have it.
So one of the most
common ones is the idea
that melodies are made
from a limited set
of discrete pitches,
seven or fewer,
and that those pitches are
arranged in some kind of scale
with unequal intervals
between the notes.
So that's as close to
a universal of music
as you can get,
although you can see
from that little
teeny black snip
that it's not quite
perfectly universal.
And the second thing
is that most music has
some kind of regular pulse,
either an isochronous
beat or even the
non-isochronous ones
have different subdivisions
with different numbers of beats
so that there's a
systematic rhythmic pattern.
So there's something kind
of like melody and something
kind of like rhythm in almost
all the world's musics.
They did find some
pretty weird ones, one
I can't resist playing for you.
This is from Papua New Guinea.
So as they say, the closest
thing to an absolute universal
was song containing
discrete pitches,
or regular rhythmic patterns,
or both, which implied
to almost the entire sample.
However, music examples
from Papua New Guinea
contain combinations of friction
blocks, swung slats, ribbon
reeds, and moaning voices--
I don't know what those
things are either,
but I'll play them
for you in a second--
that contained neither discrete
pitches nor an isochronous
beat.
OK, here we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PAPUA NEW GUINEAN MUSIC]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, pretty wild, huh?
So maybe wilder,
arguably, than John Cage.
But anyway, so there are
some like pretty remote edges
to the concept of music.
I mentioned before the case
of consonance and dissonance
and that infants don't
prefer one over the other.
In fact, this links to a
really cool recent study
from Josh McDermott's lab.
And so the question he asked is,
why do we like consonant sounds
like this--
oops, [INAUDIBLE] play.
Here we go.
[RHYTHMIC SOUND]
Kind of nice, right?
But we're not so hot about this.
[OFF TUNE SOUND]
Right, everybody
get that intuition?
OK so what's up with that?
So many people have
hypothesized for a long time
that that difference
is based in biology,
or even it's like a
physical analog of it,
beats and stuff like that.
But actually, it's an
empirical question.
And so one way to
ask that question
is to go to a culture
that's had minimal exposure
to Western music, all of which
really prefers consonance
over dissonance.
Yes, [? Carly? ?]
AUDIENCE: Is
consonants [INAUDIBLE]
differentiated [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'm sorry, totally
different word--
consonance, C-E,
has no relationship
to consonants as
distinguished from vowels.
A consonant and a vowel,
those are two different kinds
of phonemes.
Here, consonance is that
difference between those two
sounds I just played.
And it has to do with
the precise intervals
of those harmonics in
the harmonic stack.
All right, so what McDermott
and his co-workers did is to go
to a Bolivian culture in the
rainforest in a very remote
location to test these
people here, the Tsimane'.
And the Tsimane'
lack televisions
and have very little access
to recorded music and radio.
Their village doesn't have
electricity or tap water.
You can't get there by road and
you have to get there by canoe.
So that's what McDermott
and his team did.
They went down there
to visit the Tsimane'.
And what they found,
they played them
consonant sounds and dissonant
sounds, and with a translator,
and spent a lot of
time making sure
that they really understood
the difference between liking
and not liking.
And they tested
their understanding
of what it means to like
something or not like it,
and all kinds of other ways.
And the upshot is,
the Tsimane' do not
have a preference for
consonance over dissonance.
So it's not a
cultural universal.
And that's consistent
with the idea
that it's not a preference
in infants either.
So this is something
specific to Western music.
So that's kind of introduction
to some stuff about what music
is and what its
variability is and the fact
that its presence is universal.
And there are many very common
properties across the world's
musics, and it developed early.
So let's ask, is music
a separate capacity
in the mind and brain.
All right, so let's start
with the classic way
this has been asked
for many decades,
and that's to study
patients with brain damage.
And it turns out
there is such a thing
as amusia, the loss of music
ability after brain damage.
And so there are
both sides of this.
There are people who
have impaired ability
to recognize melodies without
impaired speech perception.
And there's the
opposite-- people
who have impaired speech
recognition without impaired
melody recognition.
So that is, of course, a
double dissociation, sort of,
it's a little mucky in there.
If you state the word
simply like that,
if you look in detail, there's
some muck, as there often is.
So let's look in a little more
detail at these two cases,
the most interesting ones
who seem to have problems
with auditory tunes but not with
words or other familiar sounds.
So here is a horizontal slice.
This is an old study.
So it's a CAT scan
showing you something's
up with the anterior temporal
lobes in this patient.
And this was true of these two
classic patients, CN and GL.
Both of them were very bad
at recognizing melodies, even
highly familiar melodies, happy
birthday and stuff like that,
they don't recognize.
They mostly have intact
rhythm perception.
And this is a core question
we'll come back to.
It's a complicated
non-resolved situation.
But these guys had
intact rhythm perception
and relatively intact language
and speech perception.
However, upon
further testing, it
becomes clear that these guys
have a more general problem
with pitch perception,
even if it's not
in the context of music.
So this is a question that
I asked all of you guys
to think about for in
the opposite direction
in your assignment
for Sunday night.
When I asked you
whether those electrodes
in the brains of
epilepsy patients
that are sensitive
to speech prosody,
to the intonation
contour in speech,
I asked you whether you
thought they would also
be sensitive to the intonation
contour in melodies.
And most of you said, yes, it's
pitch, pitch contour, must be.
Well, it's a perfectly
reasonable speculation,
but not necessarily.
Maybe we have special
pitch contour processing
for speech and different pitch
contour processing for music.
It's possible.
It's an empirical question.
Was there a question
back there a second?
OK, so maybe this is about pitch
for both speech and music, not
music per se.
And so there are
more detailed studies
of patients with
congenital amusia.
And just like the case
with acquired prosopagnosia
versus congenital prosopagnosia,
whether you get it
from brain damage as an adult
or whether you just always
had it your whole life, and
nobody knows exactly why
and there's no evidence
of any brain damage,
the same thing happens
with a congenital amusia.
So something like 4%
of the population,
they might say
they're tone deaf.
But just to tell
you what that means,
it can be really quite extreme.
They can just completely fail
to recognize familiar melodies
that anyone else
could recognize.
They may be unable to detect
really obvious wrong notes
in a canonical melody.
They're just really
bad at all of this.
And further, they don't have
whopping obvious problems
with speech perception.
So at first, it was thought
that speech perception was fine.
But if you look closer, it
looks like actually there
is, even outside of music,
there is a finer grained deficit
in pitch contour perception
that shows up even in speech.
So what I mentioned before, so
we can ask this in the case.
This is sort of the reverse
case of the ones you considered.
Now we have people who have
this problem with pitch contour
perception in music.
Are they going to have a
problem also with pitch contour
perception in speech?
So that's what this
study looked at.
So they played sounds like this.
And you have to
listen carefully.
There will be sentences spoken.
And you have to see if they're
identical or different.
So listen carefully.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- She looks like Ann.
She looks like Ann?
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: How many people
thought that was different?
Good, you got it.
So one is the
statement and one is--
it's sort of a question.
It's in a sort of
British accent.
It's a little harder to detect,
but different intonation
contour.
So that's what the Tang, et al.
Paper was talking about
is that distinction.
So we can then ask,
that subtle distinction,
are people with congenital
amusia impaired at that.
So if it's specific to
music, they shouldn't be.
But if it's any intonation
contour, they should be.
Yeah, I'll play the other ones.
So they are in fact impaired.
This is accuracy here, the
controls are way up there,
the amusics are down there.
So they are impaired at this
pitch contour perception thing,
even in the context of music.
I'm sorry, I said that wrong--
even in the context of speech.
So it's not just about music.
And in the controls, they
have sounds like this,
which are just tones.
Got that?
It's the same kind of
thing, but not speech.
And you see a similar
deficit in the amusics
compared to the controls.
And then they have a
nonsense speech version.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: Same deal--
the amusics are impaired
compared to the controls.
So that shows that the
deficit for these guys
is not specific to
music per se but it
seems to be a pitch contour
problem in general that
extends to speech.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Which of those--
NANCY KANWISHER: We'll
get there, sort of.
It would have been nice if the
Tang et. al. paper had included
some musical contour stuff.
They didn't, but I'll
show you some of our data
shortly that gets close to this.
OK, so all of that suggests
that this amusia is really more
about pitch than speech.
I'm sorry, what's
the matter with me.
It's really more about
pitch than music.
But the reading that
I assigned for today
is a very new twist in
this evolving story.
So this used to be a
nice, clean lecture
with a simple conclusion.
And now all of a sudden,
I ran across that paper.
It's like, wow, OK, that
might not be quite the case.
So what did you guys
get from the reading?
In what way does that slightly
complicate the story here?
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, what they found
is that amusics,
not all of them,
also have problems with rhythm.
And that is inconsistent
with the idea
that amusia is just about pitch,
whether in speech or music.
And that says, OK, many amusics
also have problems with rhythm.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: So
there's a standard battery
that people use that asks--
Dana, help me.
What does the standard
battery ask people?
AUDIENCE: There's
a lot stuff, tests,
things like listening to
like a clip of a symphony
and having to decide whether
[INAUDIBLE] or they're too
slow.
NANCY KANWISHER: Kinds
of things that people
without musical
training answer fine,
although there's quite a range.
I'm at the way bottom
end of Dana's scale
when she gives these.
AUDIENCE: That
rhythm falls apart,
might not be able to
tell the difference.
NANCY KANWISHER: Just that this
prior evidence on the stuff
I showed and a whole
bunch of other studies
seem to suggest that amusia,
both in acquired brain
damage and congenital
amusia, seem to be really
when you drill down more of
a problem with pitch per se,
even pitch in speech.
And so then if it's about pitch,
why would it also go along
with rhythm?
And so when it goes
along with rhythm,
that starts to sound more like
this is something about music.
It gums up the story.
Talia?
AUDIENCE: So I don't really know
if this could be a compound,
but when it comes
to natural speech
when you have some
kind of intonation,
like pitch differences
when you emphasize,
like especially in
terms of a question,
aren't there also some kind of
rhythmic differences as well?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
separate the two out?
NANCY KANWISHER: You just
have to do a lot of work
to try to separate those out.
And so the paper I signed to
you guys did some of that work.
There's still room to
quibble, but they did.
There was experiment
two, and they
tried to deal with exactly
that kind of thing of saying,
OK, let's try to
make sure that--
well, actually the controls
that they were doing
is slightly different.
They were to make sure that the
beat task didn't require pitch.
So it's very, very tricky
to pull these things apart,
which is--
AUDIENCE: Yes, so like the
beat task doesn't make sense,
but I was just, like,
in the verb first one,
even from the paper that
was assignment Sunday.
I don't know, so you're saying
that it's totally possible
to separate out rhythmic
differences from when
you're just changing pitch.
NANCY KANWISHER: It's
really, really difficult.
It's really difficult.
Dana's trying
to do experiments to
do this right now.
And she's invented some
delightful and crazy stimuli
that try to have one
and not the other.
It's very tricky.
You can have rhythm
without pitch change.
That you can totally do.
It's really hard or impossible
to have a melodic contour
without some beat or other.
We have some crazy stimuli
that sort of do that,
but they're pretty crazy.
So anyway, these are very
tricky things to pull apart.
And this is all right
at the cutting edge.
These things have not
been cleanly separated.
I'm running out of time.
So do you have a quick question?
OK, sorry about that.
So conclusions from
the patient literature,
they're suggestive evidence
for specialization for music,
but no really clear
disassociations.
Music deficits are
frequently but not
always associated with just
more general pitch deficits.
And all of this is
complicated because there's
lots of possible
components of music, right.
When there's pitch
deficits, is it
pitch or relative pitch,
interval, key, melody, beat,
meter?
All of these things are
different facets of music.
And so it's really not resolved
exactly what's going on here.
It's kind of encouraging that
there's a space in there,
but not resolved.
So let's go on to
functional MRI.
And we're going to
run out of time.
So let me just take a
moment to figure out
how I'm going to do this.
What the hell am I
going to do here?
Well, I hate to--
OK, you guys are going
to tell me at 12:05.
Yeah, OK.
Maybe we can get
all through this.
So here's a really charming
study from a few years ago
that tried to ask whether
there are systematic brain
regions that are engaged
in processing music.
And they used a really
fun perceptual illusion
that you're going to hear.
I'm going to play a speech clip.
And it's part of it is going
to be repeated many times.
And just listen to it and think
about what it sounds like.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- For it had never been his
good luck to own and eat one.
There was a cold
drizzle of rain.
The atmosphere was murky.
There was a cold drizzle.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: What happened?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah?
What happened?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: You
start to hear a melody.
And you didn't hear the melody
the first time he said it.
It was just normal
speech, right.
Speech has this kind
of intonation contour.
And he's speaking with
an intonation contour.
But then somehow when
you keep hearing it,
it turns into a melody.
So it turns out that doesn't
work for all speech clips.
In fact, it's really hard to
find speech clips for which it
works.
But there are some.
But everyone has that
experience, or most people do.
And that gives us a
really nice lever,
because we can take that same
acoustic sound when you hear it
as speech and when you hear
it as melody and we can ask,
are there brain regions
that respond differentially.
It's sort of analogous to
upright versus inverted faces.
Well, it's even better.
It's the exact same
sound clip that's
construed one way at first
and another way afterwards.
Everybody get that?
So that's what these guys did.
They used a standard
block design.
They just listened
to those sounds
and they just
looked in the brain
to see what bits respond more
after the sound starts getting
perceived as music
than before when
it was being heard as speech.
And they got a bunch
of blobs in the brain.
It's a bit of a mess,
but they got some stuff.
And so that's fun.
But it's also ambiguous.
We still don't know if
this is about some kind
of pitch processing, which
becomes more salient--
you hear it as abstract
pitch-- or whether it's really
about melodic contour or what.
So that's a cool study, but
I think it doesn't really
nail what's going on.
So another angle at this is
to ask whether music recruits
neural machinery for language.
So let me say why this has
been such a pervasive question
in the field.
So there's a lot of people who
have pointed out for 30 years,
or probably more, there
are many deep commonalities
between language and music.
So they're both distinctively
or uniquely human.
They're natively auditory.
That is, we can read language,
but that's very recent.
Really, language is all about
hearing, evolutionarily.
They unfold over time.
And they have complex
hierarchical structure.
So you can parse a
sentence in various ways
and there are all
kinds of people
who've come up with ways to have
hierarchical parsings of pieces
of music as well.
So there's a lot
of deep connections
between language and music.
And so many people have
hypothesized that they
use common brain machinery.
And there, in fact, many
reports from neuroimaging
that argue that in fact they
do use common machinery.
Like, we found overlapping
activation in Broca's area
for people listening
to music and speech.
However, both studies
are all group analyses.
I forget if I've gone
on my tirade in here
about group analyses.
Have I done the group
analysis tirade in here?
You'll get more of it later.
I'll do a brief version now,
and you'll get more later.
Here's the problem--
group analysis
is you scan 12 subjects.
You align their brains
as best you can.
And you do an analysis
that goes across them.
And you find some
blob, say, here, yeah,
be there, for listening to
sentences versus listening
to non-word strings.
OK, that's a standard finding.
Then you do it
again for listening
to melodies versus listening
to scrambled melodies.
And you find the blob overlaps.
And then you say, hey,
common neural machinery
for sentence understanding
and for music perception.
Now that's an interesting
question to ask.
It's close to the
right way to do it.
but there's a
fundamental problem.
And that is, you can find an
overlap in a group analysis,
even if no single subject
shows that overlap at all.
Why?
Because those regions vary
in their exact location.
And if you mush across a
whole bunch of individuals,
you're essentially blurring
your activation pattern.
And so all of the prior
studies, until a few years ago,
had been group analyses
and they found overlap.
And who the hell knows
if there was actually
overlapping activation within
individual subjects, which
there would have to be
if it's common machinery.
Or if they're just nearby
and you muck them up
with a group analysis and
they look like they're
on top of each other.
If you didn't quite
get that, we'll
be coming back to that point.
For now, all you need
to know is many people
ask this question
and the methods
were close but problematic.
But luckily,
however, Ev Fedorenko
did this experiment
right a few years ago.
So here's Ev and
here's what she did,
she functionally
identified language regions
in each subject individually.
And we'll talk more about
exactly how you do that.
You listen to sentences
versus non-word strings.
You find a systematic
set of brain regions
that you can identify in each
individual that look like this.
Here is in three subjects.
Those red bits are
the bits that respond
more when you
listen to a sentence
versus listen to
non-word strings
or read sentences
versus non-word strings.
Then what she could do is
she said, now that I found
those exact regions
in each subject,
I can ask of those
exact regions,
how do they respond to music
versus scrambled music.
So she played stuff like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, so nice canonical
and nothing crazy, weird.
We're not going with
the New Guinean music
and asking edgy questions.
We're just saying
something everybody agrees
that's music, versus
you scramble it
and it sounds like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, it's actually
the same notes.
I know, I know.
A lot of people that go, that's
cool, that's really edgy.
Yeah, it is.
But to most people, it's
not canonical music.
And so what Ev found is that
none of those language regions
responded more to the
intact than scrambled music.
So language regions are
not interested in music.
We'll talk more about that
next week or the week after.
Then she did the opposite.
She identified brain regions
here in a group analysis
just to show you where
they are, anterior
in the temporal lobes,
that respond more to intact
than scrambled music.
She identified those
in each subject
and measured the
response of those regions
to language, sentences
and non-word strings.
And each of those regions
respond exactly the same
to sentences and
non-word strings.
So basically, the
language regions
are not interested in
music, and the music regions
are not interested in language.
And therein, we have a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Thank you, exactly.
So music is not using
machinery for language.
That was one of the
hypotheses we started with.
And it was not.
So that's true, at least for
high-level language processing,
that computes the
meaning of a sentence.
But what about
speech perception?
Remember, last time I made the
distinction between the sounds,
like ba and pa, which
have a whole set
of computational challenges,
just perceiving those sounds,
which is quite
different than knowing
the meaning of a sentence.
So what about speech
perception or, in fact,
any other aspect of hearing?
So what I'm going to try to do
is briefly tell you about one
of our experiments.
I'm sorry, I try not to turn
this whole course into stuff
we've done in my lab, but
it's one of my favorite ever.
And it's a cool, different
way to go at this question
from the other MRI experiments
we've talked about before.
So the background is,
OK, let's step back.
What's the overall organization
of auditory cortex?
And when we did this experiment
five or six years ago,
not a whole lot was known.
Basically, everybody agrees.
Whoops, I put the
wrong slide in here.
Everybody agrees that primary
auditory cortex is right there
with that high-low-high
frequency thing
we talked about from there.
But from there on out, in
the last couple of years,
there's an agreement about
speech selective cortex
that I showed you
briefly last time
and other people have seen that.
But there's lots of hypotheses
and no agreement with anything
else and no real evidence for
really music-selective cortex.
But there's a problem
with all the prior work
where you sit around
and make a hypothesis
and say, oh, let's see, are
we going to get a higher
response to, say, intact versus
scrambled music, or faces
versus objects, or whatever.
All of those are scientists
making up hypotheses,
and then testing them.
And there's nothing
wrong with that.
That's what scientists
are supposed
to do-- invent hypotheses,
and then make good designs
and go test them.
But the problem with that is,
we can only discover things
that we can think to test.
What if deep facts
about mind and brain
are things that nobody would
think up in the first place?
And so that's where we can
get real power from what
are known as data-driven
studies, where you collect
a boatload of data and
then use some fancy math
and say, tell me what the
structure is in this data.
Not, is this hypothesis that
I love true in these data.
And I'll do anything to
pull it out if I can.
See it in there, find
evidence for it in there.
But yeah, exactly.
But if we collect a whole
bunch of data and do some math
and see what the structure
is, what do we see?
So that's what we
did in this study.
I'm going to speed up to try
to give you the gist here.
So "we" is Sam Norman-Haignere
here and Josh McDermott.
[SOUND RECORDING EXPERIMENT
PLAYING]
And so we scanned
people while they
were hearing stuff like this.
We first collected the
165 categories of sounds
that people hear most commonly.
This is classic cocktail party
effect you guys are doing.
You have to separate me speaking
from all this crazy, weird,
changing background.
And so anyway, we
scan people listening
to these sounds, which broadly
sample auditory experience.
And so we collected sounds
people hear most often
and that they can recognize
from a two-second clip.
OK, enough already.
[CELLPHONE RINGING]
Oh, yeah, just to
wake everyone up.
So we scan them listening to
those 165 sounds, broad sample
of auditory experience.
Then, from each
voxel in the brain,
we measure the exact magnitude
of response of that voxel
to each of the 165 sounds and
we get a vector like this.
Everybody with me?
That's one voxel right there,
another voxel, another voxel.
We do this in all
of kind of greater,
suburban, auditory cortex.
That is not just primary cortex,
but all this stuff around it
that might even remotely, that
responds in any systematic way
to auditory stimuli.
They grabbed the
whole damn thing.
So you do that in 10 subjects.
You have a big
matrix like this--
1,000 voxels in each
subject, 11,000 voxels
across the top, 165 sounds.
That's our data.
So each column is the
response of one voxel
in one person's brain to
each of the 165 sounds.
Everybody got it?
Now, we have this
lovely matrix, which
is basically all the
data we care about
from this whole experiment.
Then, we throw away
all the labels.
Poof.
It's just a matrix.
And then we do some math,
which essentially says,
let's boil down the
structure in this matrix
and discover its
fundamental components.
That math happens
to be a variant
of independent
component analysis,
if that means anything to you.
If it doesn't, don't
worry about it.
The gist is, we're
doing math to say
what's the structure in here.
And we're doing it
without any labels.
So this analysis doesn't even
know where the voxels are
or which of your 10 subjects
that voxel came from.
It doesn't know
which sound is which.
And so it's very
hypothesis neutral.
It's a way to say, show me
structure with almost no kind
of prior biases.
Just show me the structure.
So everybody get how that's kind
of a totally different thing
to do from everything
we've talked about so far?
So that's what we did.
I'm going to skip the math
and the modeling assumption.
It's not really
that complicated,
but I think I'm going
to run out of time,
so very hypothesis neutral.
And what we find
is six components
account for most of
the replicable variance
in that whole matrix.
I'll tell you what a
component is in a second.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Is it just like
with ICA, but [INAUDIBLE] PCA
[INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: With PCA,
you assume orthogonal axes.
With ICA, you don't
assume orthogonal axes.
And so it's very,
very similar to PCA.
And it starts out
as PCA and then
it does some more rigmarole.
Yeah, it's the same idea.
Like basically, tell me the
main dimensions of variation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And are these
matrices sparse and [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yes, they are sparse.
And that is one of the
assumptions you use.
There isn't only one way
to factorize a matrix.
It's an ill-posed problem.
So you need to make
some assumptions.
And that's one of the ones we
made, but you can test them.
So what we find
is six components
account for most of the data.
And four of those reflected
acoustic properties
of the stimuli.
One was high for all the sounds
with lots of low frequencies.
Another was high for all the
sounds with high frequencies.
What is that?
Sorry, speak up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: They're
sensitive to frequency,
but where is that in the
brain that you've already
heard about?
AUDIENCE: Primary--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Primary auditory cortex
as a tonotopic map.
So this is awesome.
Because if you go
invent some crazy math
and you apply it to your data
and you discover something
you know to be true,
that's very reassuring.
The math isn't just
inventing crazy stuff.
It's discovering stuff we
already know to be true.
That's known in more
biological parts of the field
as a positive control.
Invent a new method,
make sure it can discover
the stuff you know to be true.
So check, check, OK.
But then it discovered
some other stuff.
And I'm just going to tell
you about two of them.
So here's one.
So I was just loose about
what a component is.
A component is a magnitude of
response for each of the 165
sounds and a
separate distribution
in the brain, which I'll
show you in a moment.
So here's one of
those components.
And we've taken the 165 sounds
and added basic category
labels on them.
We put them on Mechanical
Turk and people told us
which category they belong to.
So that enables us to look
at this mysterious thing
and average within a category.
So this is its component.
And if you look at
it, you see that it's
really high for English
speech and foreign speech
that our subjects
don't understand.
And then, oh, what's,
that intermediate Thing
Oh, that's music with vocals.
It has a kind of speech.
And way down here--
that's non speech vocalizations,
stuff like laughing
and crying and sighing.
So there's a voice
but no speech content.
So that's a speech component.
And as I mentioned,
this had been seen
before in the last few years.
So it wasn't completely new.
But what's cool about this
is just emerged spontaneously
from this very broad screen.
We didn't go and
say, hey, can we
find a speech selective
region of cortex,
if we try really hard.
Oh, yeah, we validate
our hypothesis.
This is like, let's sample
auditory experience-- and wow,
there it is.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I mean, you
assigned [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER:
We put them on Turk
and had people say what
category they fit into.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Categorizing by speech is
a very good way [INAUDIBLE]
better way than [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER:
Absolutely, absolutely.
This is a first pass.
And one hopes to go
deeper and deeper.
If we could separate different
aspects of speech, consonants
and vowels,
fricatives, whatever,
there could be much
more to be done.
Yeah, I got to--
oh, boy, OK.
And when do I have to
give them the quiz?
It's shortish.
They don't need a
full 10 minutes.
What is it?
Seven questions?
AUDIENCE: Eight.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Eight-- eight minutes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, make me
stop definitively at 12:18.
OK, so that's cool.
It's not exactly new, but
it's a really nice way
to rediscover things that
we thought to be true.
All right, then there's
component 6 that popped out.
What is component 6?
Well, if we average
within a category
instrumental music
and music with vocals,
and everything
else is really low.
We didn't go looking for this.
Boom-- music selectivity.
That's pretty amazing.
Never really been seen before.
People have looked
and they've made
some kind of sort of smoke
and mirrors, like, not really.
This is the first
time it was seen
and it just popped
out of the data.
And that says that
it's not just something
you can find if you try really
hard and go fishing for it.
It's actually a significant
part of the variance
in this whole response.
I'm going to skip everything
except clarification questions
now, because I'm--
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Did these
voxels correspond
to the music [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: Sort
of, it's complicated.
Sorry, it's a long answer.
So this really looks
like it's music.
And so now, I was vague
about what a component is,
but it's both that
response profile
and it's a set of
weights in the brain.
So if you project this
one back in the brain,
you get this band of
speech selective cortex
right below primary
auditory cortex, like that.
And if you project the music
stuff back in the brain,
you get a patch.
This is sort of an
answer to your question.
You get a patch up in
front of primary auditory
cortex and a patch behind.
So here we have a
double dissociation
of speech selectivity and music
selectivity in the brain, OK?
So music doesn't just
use mechanisms for speech
as many people have proposed.
It's not true, right.
So when you see
dramatic data like this,
a natural reaction is to say,
like, really, get out, come on.
Like, music
specificity, like what?
So very briefly, Dana
has just replicated this
in a new sample of subjects.
It does not matter if those
subjects have musical training,
like students from
Berklee School who
spend like six hours
a day practicing,
versus people who
have essentially
zero music lessons
ever in their life,
you get those components in both
groups, maybe slightly stronger
in the trained musicians.
We're not quite sure yet.
But in any case, it is
totally present in people
with zero musical training.
That doesn't mean it's
innate, because people
without musical training
have musical experience
but no explicit training.
Skip all of this.
Here is her replication.
Boom, boom.
It's there with and
without training.
I'm going to skip all this.
You can read it on the
slides, if I lost you
in here, because I want to
show you something else.
That music selectivity
was not evident
if you just do a direct
contrast in the same data.
Take all the music conditions,
all the non-music conditions,
you get a blurry mess.
It's not strong.
You have to do the
math to siphon it off.
And that's OK.
But I like to see
things in the raw data.
And so probably
what that means is
that the music is overlapping
with other things in the brain.
And so the direct contrast
doesn't work well,
the math can pull them apart.
But wouldn't it be nice
to see them separately?
And so we've been doing
intracranial recordings
from patients with
electrodes in their brain.
And I'll just show you a
few very cool responses.
So this is a single electrode
in a single patient.
These are the 165
sounds, same ones.
This is the time course.
And this is a speech
selective electrode.
It responds to native
and foreign music.
Those are the two green ones--
I'm sorry, native
and foreign speech.
And it responds to music
with vocals in pink.
Everybody see how that's a
speech selective electrode?
So there's loads of those.
But we also found these.
Here is a single electrode.
Look, each row is
a single stimulus.
Here's a histogram of responses
to all the music with vocals,
music without vocals, much
stronger than to anything else.
You might be saying, well,
what about those things.
Let's look at what
those things are.
Oh, even the violations
aren't really violations.
Whistling, humming,
computer jingle, ringtone--
those are sort of musicy.
So that is an extremely
music-selective
individual electrode in
a single subject's brain.
No fancy math that might
have invented it somehow.
It's just there right
in the raw data.
Further, and here's
the time course,
you can see the time course of
music with instruments, music
with vocals, everything else.
Really selective.
So this is the
strongest evidence yet
for music specificity
in the human brain.
But there's one more cool thing
that came out of this analysis.
And that is we found
some electrodes
that are not just
selected for music,
but selected for vocal
music, selected for song.
And that's really amazing.
Because as I started
off at the beginning,
many people have
said that song is
a kind of native form of music.
The first one to evolve
and all that kind of stuff.
And so we did all the controls.
It's not the low-level stuff.
And there's lots
of open questions.
We started with this
puzzle of how did
music evolve, if it did evolve.
And we made a little
bit of progress.
It doesn't share music machinery
with speech and language.
If it's auditory
cheesecake, as Pinker said,
it's auditory cheesecake that
not only uses machinery that
evolved for something
else, but changes it
throughout development and
makes it very selective.
These guys speculated
that song is special.
Maybe it is.
And sexual selection, who knows?
We have no data.